son las 9 de la mañana e Iván está en su
tercer entrenamiento del día estriata de
élite y entrenador ahora además es
candidato a concejal de deportes para la
alcaldía de Madrid yo creo que nos iría
bastante mejor si en todas las áreas en
todas las competencias del ayuntamiento
de Madrid tuviéramos un político menos y
un profesional más el 28 de mayo hay
elecciones municipales y regionales en
España en la capital por primera vez una
iniciativa ciudadana Presenta una opción
para llenar la alcaldía de ciudadanos
expertos en temas concretos y no de
políticos
Cuando entras en un partido político
empiezas a escalar y bueno al final te
tienen que colocar en una de las
competencias Pero tú seguramente no
sepas de esa competencia en este caso al
no ser políticos a ser profesionales
desde hace muchísimo tiempo en esas
competencias sí que sabemos de lo que
vamos a hablar Buenos días En este acto
de campaña está Anel y Matos de
República Dominicana y tercera en la
lista de recupera Madrid con otros 57
profesionales insiste en la importancia
de que los migrantes se involucren en la
vida pública y que los que puedan voten
en las municipales es importante que
salgamos que estemos que nos empapemos
de la ciudad en la que vivimos porque
nosotros vivimos aquí trabajamos aquí y
por lo tanto tenemos mucho que aportar a
esta ciudad en 2019 más del 35% del
electorado en Madrid no fue a las urnas
esta realidad es la que quiere reflejar
el partido escaños en blanco que
pretende captar a los electores que
votan nulo en blanco o se abstienen pero
lo que hacemos Es en caso de salir
elegidos no Juramos el cargo Entonces
ese escaño se queda vacío esta
candidatura renuncia también a
subvenciones dietas o sueldos o lo que
queremos es que se vea si hay algún tipo
de problema Y a partir de ahí se abre un
debate sobre Qué es cuál es el problema
que hay alternativas viables Aunque
minoritarias en una ciudad que en las
últimas tres décadas y media ha tenido
30 años de alcaldías de derecha o centro
derecha